did you ever think you make it I feel
I'm so I T Victory I know this life for
me why would you bet on Goliath when we
got bet David value taming giv values
contagious this world entrepreneurs we
no value
toomie look what I become
the for if you wanted I have a great
orang e story from Orange this morning
uh uh Adam was having a have to you know
Shar this with the audience it's just
purely all about integrity this morning
Adam was drinking coffee and I smelled
it I'm not going to lie to you that was
the most incredible smell yeah coffee
hat I like the smell of coffee I'm just
not drinking it because I still don't
need it yes I'm still going to do
something I feel like a drug de right
all right home team back at it um I am
coffee so home team uh lots of stories
we didn't get into yesterday there's a
couple weird videos you have to see one
of them which is just unbelievable you
know the one thing you have to give
credit to the marketing team of uh uh
Biden Jill Biden when when they're
picking locations to give speeches they
they just they're so fantastic at
picking the right locations timely the
name of the high school wait till you
see when I show it to you you'll also
agree with me to say you know their
their marketing person gets credit if
it's satire if that person's trying to
play a joke on them he's he deserves a
raise I I'll quit and I wouldn't be
surprised if you know Trump offered him
a job and said you come to our side
after what you just said we'll show that
clip to you stepen schwarzman
billionaire says uh what Trump needs to
do to get his support again and it's
interesting we'll talk about that Trump
spack you know truth social is up a
175% wow in a Six-Day rally why is that
we'll process that buy out pay later
holiday debt hangover has arrived and
consumers are wondering how the hell
they're going to pay it back we'll cover
the story we couldn't do yesterday trans
golfer Haley Davidson Vinnie's got some
uh Insight on this this person wins
women's tournament increasing chances to
LPGA qualifier Bernie Sanders wife
accepted $116,000 book advaned in 2017
but the book is still not here and it's
2024 it's been 7 years okay Goldman
Sachs um says they see four rate Cuts 2%
inflation for 2024 stock market ready
Dow hits 28,000 for the first time ever
I'm sorry what did I say 35 she said 28
38 38,000 for the first time smpi is
another record Oakland
California uh only In-N-Out restaurant
closing due to Crime can you imagine
In-N-Out that's never had a problem with
traffic when have you heard about it in
and not closing ever right do never
never they're closing down because of
the amount of crime they're having and
there's a whole other story about
California which we're going to get into
as well yeah they have a line even at
midnight in California every location
that's right false advertising because
in and it could easily be in and hang
out by the that's right the one in
Burbank we used to go to hang out a lot
but Tom's got some data the homelessness
numbers just came out for 2023 and they
have three specific States they're
talking about California Florida and
Texas wait to see these numbers
Washington State Democrats you ready for
this little weird propose replacing the
term sex offender to advance a ready
person first approach what what yeah
they want to replace the term sex
offender to person first approach okay
who knows what that means but we we'll
talk about that immigration overtakes
inflation as top voter concerns poll so
officially immigration's number one
MSNBC Joy Reed rips into moms for
Liberty founder for objecting a
book very very interesting why she would
even take the approach that she did but
it is what it is Biden's doj finally
admits Hunter Biden's laptop is real we
didn't talk about that yesterday we will
touch on that today Ohio lawmakers I I
really want to get into this story I
think we may even start off with the
first one here being this Ohio lawmakers
proposed paying students money to attend
school and graduate okay we we'll touch
on that Elon Musk feeds viral iracy
theory that Patriots front actually are
feds we have a video we'll show you make
a decision for yourself Willam musk
politics impact Tesla uh and then we
have Ravens head coach John Harbaugh
recites Bible verse to open press
conference after playoff win and then
stories come about from few years ago
that he would choose to raise the baby
of any Michigan and this is his brother
Jim would rais the baby of any Michigan
football player who got a grow pregnant
that's dealing with unplanned pregnancy
talk about a family that's a True
Believer yeah childless future birth
rate plunging as Millennials decide
against being parents this story from
Yahoo finance I thought it's also
interesting more single women are buying
homes single women are buying homes uh
NATO War we may talk about that clab we
may talk about that Charlamagne the God
says Biden has never been a good
candidate was elected due to Unfortunate
Events maybe we'll talk about that as
well so having said that before we get
into all these stories I want to go to
our latest sponsor that we just brought
on board Nia Rob if you can play this
clip and then we'll get into the story
of Ohio lawmakers proposing to pay
students uh who attend school and
graduate go ahead and play the clip so
look every single year one of the things
you got to do as a business own or
entrepreneur is take inventory of your
tools and say is this the best tool
we're using today and is this the most
coste effective way for us as a company
to save money one of the tools no matter
what industry you're you're in that you
have to be aware of is your
communication tool our sponsor today is
nextiva nextiva is a voice over Internet
Protocol which means it's a system that
you can create phone numbers in
different area codes so if you're in
real estate Insurance Dialing for deals
nextiva will help you get more answers
and close more deals you'll get
unlimited calling business texting and
auto attended voice analytics and many
many more features that'll make your
business look as polished as a Fortune
500 company nextiva is one of the most
affordable ways I know you can grow your
business in
2024 don't let the tools you're
currently using hold you back go to try
next eva.com pbd to get up to 50% off
your plan and talk to an next Diva rep
to see if it's the right tool for
you there you go again I've used a lot
of tools over the years it's very
important to use the right ones highly
recommend you go take a look at these
guys and see if they're fit for you okay
let's get into it Ohio lawmakers propose
paying students to attend school and and
graduate interesting concept right so
and wait to hear Tom's view on this as a
parent and uh it's it may surprise some
of you so Ohio lawmakers Bill sites and
Danny Isaacson have introduced
bipartisan legislation proposing a pilot
program set to launch in 2024 2025
school year which will reward students
for good attendance as a measure to
combat chronic absentismo
of Education and Workforce aims to
provide cash transfers to select
kindergarten and ninth grade students in
Ohio students with a 90% or higher
attendant will receive $25 cash
transfers every two weeks followed by
150 at the end of each quarter and a
final reward of $500 at the end of
school year if they maintain the
attendance criteria Additionally the
lawmakers are suggesting a graduation
incentive pilot program in the same
Academic Year offering students from
select schools up to 7 $50 for
graduating with high gpas with the goal
of improving graduating rates Tom I love
this Ohio finally makes an economic
decision here's an economic decision I
read just looked it up that the
incarceration rate for County jail now
we're not talking about federal prisons
County Jail cost the taxpayers
$36,000 per year per person per person
so in other words to have one one bed in
that jail county jail for and this is
where by the way if you get a DOI you
know you may be two days there or you
may have to go to court and have 14 days
there this is County and this is where a
lot of first and second time offenders
of you know uh drug possession and
things end up they're not in the federal
prison system yet so they're looking at
this and saying how do we give an
incentive an oh here's a novel term an
allowance this basically allowance to
students to stay in attendance because
staying in school and not dropping out
has a direct correlation with their
ability to earn money and a direct
correlation with how many times they get
busted for petty theft and things like
this so if they stay in
school it's better it's better for
society so Ohio is saying wait a minute
I don't know if they're thinking this
way but it's the way I think hey instead
of putting $36,000 a year on the
taxpayer why don't we spread it out and
give these kids an incentive to stay in
school and stay attend and instead of
welfare you're giving well attendance
check I think this is a great idea what
do you think well I mean it's a good
idea in that sense to try to get them
there but what's to say that these
people these bad kids are just going to
show up just to get the money it's not
going to make them want to learn or be
better people if I knew listen I'm going
to make $1,000 or $750 like $7 i' just
Cal Patrick and I would just sit there
I'd still be if I was a menace and
wanted to skip and go do crazy stuff I'm
just going to do it in the school now
you know what you know you know I think
it's missing two steps in my opinion
what I think is good about this idea is
they're going the right so while Tom was
talking and looking at all the said
$36,000 per year per person that's in
jail I looked at what Ohio's rate is for
the number of people that go to jail
it's 659 Rob if you can pull this up 659
per 100,000 is what their number of uh
uh uh number no 659 per 100,000 Ohio has
a population of uh 11.78 million which
means that roughly
77,000 659 per 100,000 and uh they have
77,000 people in jail if you take 77,000
people in jail times 36,000 you know
what that is that is $2.79 billion uh
I'm sorry yeah $2.79 billion a year to
the state wow that's a lot of money
right okay who pays for that sales tax
sales tax right okay no problem so am I
willing to pay
pay $25 every two weeks and $150 end of
each quarter and $500 end of the year
for having 90% attendance uh no maybe
I'll create tiers and here's how I would
do it I would do tier one is you have to
be there and get a minimum of C's at the
bottom okay okay so worst case you get
all C's you get 1 D you ain't getting
your 25 bucks got to be C or higher okay
I like that then if you go C's and B's
and higher I go 50 bucks and then you
get straight A's I go 100 bucks and then
if you're in the top five I'll create
teers in the class five gets this four
gets this three gets this number one
gets $5,000 okay that $5,000 will be
used for you know college uh whatever
scholarship right the only thing I have
a problem with this is kindergarten if
if the kid is late to kindergarten it's
on parent it's got nothing to do so I
would change this is from the age where
the kid can come to school maybe I'd
started at Junior High School from sixth
grade the hell am I doing paying bonuses
for kindergarteners they don't even know
what the hell is going on parents are
going to take that money and say thank
you it's not the kids money it's going
to go to the parents money there's a
part of this I like incentive program to
provide and produce the right habits I'm
for that well I think at that point you
can uh tax the adult for if his kid is
late to school sorry you owe us money
buddy sorry your kid's going to get in a
fight with his dad you ow us the 25
let's go buddy I'm going to make 25
bucks today but I think uh anything that
encourage an incentive program to
encourage showing up the school to
learning getting better grades I think
is great if you take a a bigger
perspective of what's going on in the
education system I think we're all
recognizing whatever the current
structure of the education system
specifically the public education system
ain't working Chico so they got to
figure out something that's a little bit
more vibrant and sort of restructure
what's going on out there incentive
programs for sure attendance for sure
good grades for for sure you have any
ideas anything to the idea cuz we got
stor well I want to understand something
yeah we all if you look at what's going
on in the college system because
basically High School is just a farm
system to go to college right that we
all know that college at this point is a
scam if you look at the numbers for
college Americans are overwhelming
losing faith in colleges in 2013 74%
said there was important to go to
college now it's
41% people don't believe that it's
important to go to college anymore
people in 20 um same year 2013 is
college going in the right direction or
the wrong direction 61% said wrong
direction 38% right direction so it it
starts with the elementary schools it
starts with the middle schools it starts
with the high schools incentivizing the
right Behavior incentivizing why you're
there incentivizing why you're learning
so when you go there last Point
recognition we do a monthly recog nition
and value tainment hey you did a great
job with the editor hey your Channel's
growing hey you're crushing it and
everyone gets up they clap they get a GI
certificate they get a football whatever
it is it's important to recognize the
kids that are showing up and doing well
in school and one Parting Shot here is
the state of Florida has a thing called
the Bright Futures program and the
Bright Futures program in the State of
Florida if you get a 3.5 GPA and this is
any school Pat any school so even if
you're in a troubled school right you're
in a really tough High School low
academic standards there you get a 3.5
GPA and you do like I think it's 100
service hours the State of Florida will
give you a free education at Florida
State University of Florida or UCF the
state schools so Florida got with this
program a while ago to encourage kids
coming from moderate incomes hey just
just get a in work the right incentives
work by the way you know what I don't
understand is why uh who was a number
one number one student last year in the
state of Florida
the number one stud who was the number
one student last year in the State of
Florida who was the number 10 who had
the highest GP in the State of Florida
what kids last year got 1600 on their
SATs in the State of Florida or Texas or
California or New York why don't we know
that stuff why why doesn't the state
tweet it out well you mean to tell me
parents wouldn't recognize it I don't I
don't think this when when they asked me
what is the biggest problem that's going
on the last four years I said number one
problem we have in America is a hero
making machine if we're not if we're not
doing the hero making machine
recognition I want to know which kids
crushed it and have media talk about it
when you talked about that was one
especially about teachers and giving
them shout outs and letting us know but
by the way this could backfire cuz if
you're in Ohio and you're a parent
you're like I don't want to work I'm
going to pump out 10 kids put them all
in school every year like you keep your
ass in school that's a paycheck paycheck
paycheck yeah I don't think it's enough
money to pay the bills I get what you're
saying if they get it to that point
you're right you're right okay let's go
to by the way this kind of goes
perfectly with the next story on what's
going on in the state of California and
California so where's that story by
California's uh U Wasing Oakland okay
there you go Oakland California only in-
andout Restaurant closing due to Crime
page six if you want to go to it and
this leads me with okay so the only inab
burer location Oakland California is
closing due to surgeon crime including
car break-ins property damage theft and
armed robberies of customers and
employees according to the company in
andout do Chief Operating Officer Danny
Warwick stated top priority must be the
safety and the well-being of our
customers and Associates we cannot ask
them to visit to work or work in an
unsafe environment the closure comes
after repeated attempts to deter crime
and maximize safety as in the last day
of operation for the oakport street
location is March 24th current employees
will have the option to work at nearby
locations or receive severance package
es Tom what what stats do you have with
what's going on in California obviously
what's your opinion on this but I know
the homelessness stat just came up from
California and I know Rob's got it do
you mind going through that both of it
the story and reaction to the stats this
this Oakland is self-explanatory what's
been happening in Oakland you've got
tremendous homelessness over there in
the greater Bay Area you you you you've
got that that uh poop location map that
uh DeSantis pulled out of his pocket
when he and Gavin Nome did that debate
um and that's a real map and that that
kind of thing is happening in New York
and other things so what's what's
happening this is you know homelessness
and oh you know defund the police and
everything it's all coming home to see
it but our government keeps track of
homelessness and check this out uh Rob
do you have it at the end of last year
let's see the cover of the report real
quick who was that face we just saw that
was John we're by way go back cuz you
just threw me off same guy yeah we'll
get into that go the other way you were
going the right direction you frightened
me don't show me that and so this is our
our very own here it is the
2023 annual homelessness assessment
report to Congress by Hud right Housing
and Urban Development so this is our
government reporting on itself its
states and it came out at December
released around the holiday time without
a press release and without any Fanfare
I wonder why a rather blue Congress
would not want a lot of fanfare let's
find out so we take the top three
population States you go to those three
Rob right there here's the top three
population States and here's the report
on those States this report had all 50
states and we're going to play a game in
a minute called called red blue love it
red blue but right now California coming
so people would say oh stats can be
overblown because there's more people
live in the state less people live in
the state hey let's look at it on an
equal basis for every 10,000 people in
California
46 are homeless and 68% have zero
shelter that is that is a sleeping bag
on the street a sleeping bag on the
street now PE for Gavin Newsome that
likes to
brag take a look at Florida 14 people
per 10,000 so in other words on an equal
percentage
basis California's four times worse
homelessness than Florida what about
Texas you know things are going on that
guess what it's 9 out of 10,000 meaning
that California is five times although
California Texas is going to Skyrocket
by the end of 2024 because of the way
Governor Abbott's handled the border
that number is not going to look at by
the end of 2024 and by the way I looked
up because people say things are
changing so I looked up the 2022 report
California has gone from 44 to 46 out of
10,000 wow Florida went from 12 to 14
and Texas went from 8 to 9 so
homelessness is up in all three states
but what's really interesting to look
Texas only 42% of them but that's still
bad are actually unsheltered on the
street so if you look at the green
that's what that's the people living
like on the street completely
unsheltered and Florida it's about 50/50
but these are the stats these are the
stats you want to talk about your state
you got to look at numbers you know
what's amazing is and he'll go on Bill
Mar yesterday okay and I I don't know if
you guys had a chance to see it did you
watch the whole of course watch the
thing if you watch him on Bill Maher you
again his ability to to spin everything
as if he Gavin he's a
[__] B [__] artist and he his
ability to tell you know what they're
doing and how much he cares and all this
stuff and Bill and Bill Mar's like look
I don't like how divisive this is being
that's being red state blue State I
don't like that you're doing that he
says look I agree with that I think we
all want to be loved I think we all want
to be liked and I want to be liked and I
love Florida I love the people in
Florida but what are you going to do are
you going to let all these guys attack
ESC Dei any three-letter word that they
get are we going to let them do that and
it's only the red State people that are
doing that so this is happening under
his watch by the way I want you to think
about this okay economically who has
hurt the state of California the worst
since California was a state name
anybody you can name gangsters you can
name Mobsters you can name you know
gangs blood and [__] you can name
technology you can you can name
anybody who in the history of California
hurt the state's conditions and economy
the worst since 1851 think about names
Tom what names would you give you lived
in California what names would you say
hurt the State of Affairs in California
the economy the most wow uh there was a
governor named Democrat Governor Gray
Davis who got recalled and shot out of a
cannon and Arnold Schwarzenegger
replaced him and Gavin Nome you can look
at their record it's leadership at the
top you know what's the difference
though during Davis the net migration
rate didn't Skyrocket the way it did
under Nome back to back to back he may
go down as the worst person in the
history of the state of California that
hurt the economy of California I don't
think there is anybody
that's hurt the economy worse than Gavin
Nome just the economy you're talking
about just overall homelessness dirty if
California was a company is the worst Co
they've ever had I I agree no no because
because a CO is judged on what what's a
CO judged on how happy people are no
what's Co judge done numbers and data
num okay so how did these guys go from
thata Tom they had a 97 billion doll
Surplus last year ex they lost 72
billion last year how do you do that
they they had a 90 billion plus dollar
so give or take and they're down 70
billion a year how do you spend all that
money how do you go through all that
money historically this guy if he was a
CEO in California was a business it's
the worst CEO California has ever had
and you want to see this is what his
stock chart and by the way he will still
run for president he's still for States
please take a look at this California
the homeless rate is increased 30% since
2007 Florida it's decreased 36% Texas
decreased 31 % so if you look at that as
a long-term stock chart on homelessness
it's basically they've run California
into the ground and and guys one this
really fast time so they tried to recall
him with uh Larry Elder as a voter as a
person are you that blinded everybody
that lives there in California to me is
like yeah everything sucks they all
complain but they're like yeah but the
weather they always turn to the weather
how do you not recall a guy like
blatantly in your face that is
absolutely horrible how do you not vote
them all I'll give you a little
perspective yeah yeah go ahead there's
two things here real quick and we'll go
straight to Adam they successfully put
him on the ballot the citizen
successfully petitioned had enough
signatures to get him on the ball recall
but there was no one that was strong
enough politically against him that's
what happened got okay no I mean look so
you're saying Larry wasn't strong Larry
Elder wasn't strong enough he there was
not a strong enough candidate but he was
ripe for the taking we can do all the
data we can do all the stats and anybody
that actually is paying attention will
look into this and be like like oh wow
nobody's reading into these stats
nobody's doing the due diligence
nobody's doing the research cuz it's all
based on feelings these days and we know
that politics is a feelings game how do
I feel about the candidate how do they
make me feel we've always heard you know
for facts don't care about your feelings
but most people these days operate on
emotion and feelings they're going over
personality over policy so we saw that
debate when Gavin Nome was up against
the santis and I'm in Florida I'm a
Florida guy you guys are all you know
lived in California your whole life I'm
looking at this and I'm
like everything is on desantis's side
here this homeboy is busting out poop
maps to show you what a [__] show
literally literally California is and at
the end of the debate they said who won
the debate they're like oh uh gav gome
won it's like stop it with the stats you
have to make people feel a certain type
of way we can get into basically what
the santis
his lack of ability in order to do that
but if you're running against Nome the
way that you the way that you can beat
someone like that is not with stats
because he's gonna he's such a slick
skilled politician you have to draw a
motion do you understand that in Gavin
news California In-N-Out Burgers will
cease to exist yeah people are like not
my In-N-Out Burgers yeah exactly people
love I mean we used to go to the one in
in uh in Addison the best this is the
type of guy that will run all your
favorite stores all your favorite bers
you're making a very by the way you're
making a very very good point I mean
it's been a while but you're making a
very good
point did the question it's about
leadership you're talking about leaders
the real question is did he hit the can
I have the pink charts P charts if I if
I may you you're you're making a very
good point and the reason why that's a
very good point is is because all of
this is storytelling right it's all
storytelling you know I had one of my
guys spoke to yesterday and he's
creating content and one of his
strengths is he's one of the best
storytellers we've ever had in the
history of the company but when he's
doing his videos all he's talking about
is facts facts facts and it's logic
logic logic I said dude you're one of
the best storytellers tell a flipping
story okay tell a good story take a
minute tell a story okay I remember 2009
when this happened to me and d d d and
then boom tell the story you know how to
tell a story you don't no one needs to
teach you a person who naturally is a
good Storyteller you don't need to teach
them how to tell a story just let her
rip and don't even give him any feedback
just go do what you do right and the
right is trying to win arguments with
Logic the left is winning arguments by
emotion and you need both uh you know
this whole book that just came out
choose your enemies wisely the breakdown
of business planning for the longest
time everything I you know would sit
down with guys and they would write a
plan it was all logic logic logic logic
logic and I would have guys that would
only write emotion emotion emotion and
both of them will lose
okay but typically the emotion one had a
little bit of an edge over the logic guy
okay typically because they had a bigger
reason to fight and they wouldn't quit
but you give me the guys that can do
logic and emotion the right has all the
logic on their side they have the stats
on their side right now you just have to
tell stories of what's going on New York
let me let me read you the story with
New York here's New York for you ready
Rob what page is the New York one you
just text me there you go 10 New York
City neighborhood turned into a giant
toilet as migrants litter part with poop
leave cups of urine on doorsteps what
leaving cups of urine imagine you wake
up in the morning there's cups of urine
on your doorsteps so a recent report
highlights significant sanitation
problem in New York City's Tomkin Square
Park primarily caused by migrants
waiting outside an East Village intake
center after their shelter State limited
expired limits expired Port Port porta
potties were removed due to to extreme
filth leaving the area without adequate
restroom facilities according to local
residents gared Roso migrants were using
plastic cups to urinate and he spotted a
dozen cups filled with urine Guardian
Angels founder Curtis Silva criticized
mayor Adams for his handling of the
migrant stating he's the Swagger man
with no plan everything he does it's a
knee-jerk reaction with no followup it
so again when you see data and you see
results and you show these videos and
you see how see how unhappy people are
bad you know bad policies have
consequences you're seeing it in New
York and in California and what and
here's the thing what did you expect
okay what did you expect you open the
door you let everybody in they're
pooping they're pissing I have reports
from my cousins from New York guess what
now the migrants are knocking on
people's doors going hey panhandling at
your door and it's only a matter of time
what do you me that they're knocking on
people's doors going hey you have a
dollar they want money they they're like
you know in the corner when you stop at
a light homeless people come to your car
I swear to God Pat they're coming to the
door knocking and going money some guy I
forgot where a guy was interviewed I saw
my next he's like I pay my taxes I I've
never been late I've always he goes now
that you guys are opening up this place
busting people in and now they're coming
to the door and now guess what this is
first it's pooping piss knocking on your
door next thing is going to be when
they're when they have no hope they're
coming into your house just wait and see
you're talking about the year of chaos
spot it's coming because it's gradually
happening what do you mean by coming to
your house like hey you got an extra
spare room
somebody robbing the house cuz bro once
when somebody is back into a corner and
they have nothing these if they can't
pee or piss anywhere it's a matter of
time to where they're starving and
they're like we're coming in your effing
house and it's only a matter of time
since until the narrative changes in New
York we say this all the time when we're
in New York hey I'm walking here and
soon it's going to be like hey I'm
pissing here bro like like it's going to
change dramatically it's leadership and
we need leaders that are Dynamic that
can not only and this may sound familiar
uh cuz I'm coach can not only drive but
sell and I feel like the conservatives
know how to drive and drive stats and I
tend to be on that side but you also
have to be able to sell you have to be
able to sell your position be a great
leadership let's play a fast fast fast
game and we'll get to the next topic Rob
the pink chart please this Tom's got his
gam charts this is the homeless report
you yell or blue when I name a state
this is the top 10 that are on the
homeless and this is leadership what's
going on District of Columbia Blue
California blue Vermont blue Oregon Blue
Hawaii blue New
York blue Washington blue Maine blue
Alaska blue red no you got caught buddy
nine of the top 10 you got caught alas
come on but the point is point is why is
this why are the voters still electing
leadership in these in these states
where the homelessness is so bad leading
to people peeing in cups knocking on
your door and actually panhandling and
you making you concerned about the
security of your family the Republicans
have to come out the conservatives have
to come out and we have to not only not
only drive home the stats and talk about
the facts we also have to sell the
vision and sell we need Dynamic
candidates to come out there who can not
only lead but can drive you have to sell
and drive if you want to know how
corrupt this situation has become I I I
get these lists I mean we can do that
look at number one on the list and it's
not even Clos by the way 65 United
States that that that is dictating
policy all across the country is an
absolute
disaster 50% worse than any state but
but but a but by the way it's all by
Design it's all for the votes look like
think about what's happening in Texas
this because by the way the majority of
all that District Columbia they're all
coming in through Texas do you
understand that the Jo Joe Biden's White
House is suing Texas because Texas is
trying to protect the border with the
barbwire do like think about that think
about that Texas is overrun the
government is going who the hell do you
think you are Texas by stopping this
influx of democrat votes think about
that so and let's just be honest
everybody in power from the White House
hedge fund managers Supreme Court they
don't give a [__] about your safety they
want everybody to come in and at what
point Texas they have to I'm not saying
take up arms and shoot migrants but you
got to protect your border bro because
it's only a matter of time till these
people come in and then here's my thing
Adam if one illegal person kills one
American in a car accident or rapes and
kills or whatever whatever that's too
much for me and if that means you got to
protect yourself CU they don't give a
[__] about you by the way let me go to
the story immigration overtakes
inflation as top voter concern this is a
poll that just came up that now this is
as of January 22nd the hill and the
story is immigration has searched as the
top policy concern amongst among voters
with 35% of respondents listing it as
their Paramount concern marking a 7%
Point increase compared to the previous
month's poll inflation followed closely
behind with 32% of respondents when
asked about personal impact 38% of
respondents indicated that inflation
affects them directly while 17%
mentioned immigration the number of
respondents citing immigration's
personal impact increased by 3% uh point
of the previous survey despite a
reduction of inflation immigration
remains a significant political issue
with both Republicans and some Democrats
emphasizing a majority of Voters 64%
believe that conditions at the border
are worsening and 68% believe that the
administration should make it tougher to
enter the us legally reflecting a
bipartisan desire for stricter border
enforcement Adam makes total sense to me
because you know don't look now but the
economy has been doing better there's a
story here about basically how people
are feeling a little bit more
optimistic um on the economy inflation
has cooled down to somewhere around 3%
these days if you ask the average
American what's the what is the
inflation rate right now they would tell
you it's probably 7 8 9 10% the FED has
actually done a decent job of what they
would call a soft Landing in the economy
not so much Boeing but that's a whole
another story but that's a hot Landing
exactly unemployment right now is at 3
and a half% we just saw the stock market
reach record high is 38,000 I remember
being in Dallas shooting a video when we
reached 30,000 in 2020 20 but there is a
difference between Wall Street and Main
Street we understand that but the
economy seems to be doing on the right
track we'll see what happens with the
with the um with the interest rates and
you know whether they're going to give a
pause and all that but speaking of
Storytelling nothing makes you feel more
angered as an American just to see the
open border Caravans unbelievable
pouring into the country you even have
Democrats right now like John fedman
who's just using Common Sense guys this
isn't a left or right thing it's a an
American thing what is happening at the
border guys when you see images like
this how left do you have to be to say
yeah I'm totally fine with that the
questions need to be answered so to give
a to give a bottom line on this totally
understand why the immigration in the
border is now at the top of the list
versus the econ because because it's
coming it's coming to their doorstep
literally and when you have loser
leftist Shields like Jim masto when
Trump was in and he's like it's an inv
he goes I consider an invasion and Jim
is like what are you talking about
they're just people looking for Refuge
it's people like that and that's why
when they call them the enemy of the
people you are because that is an
invasion and I'll say it again one
American dies because of that I think we
go to the people are suing them people
are going to the government to sue them
because not one life should be lost and
not one school should be shut down for I
don't give a [__] for how long because
we have to put migrants illegal people
inside of a school because it's cold
outside that's [__] just to ju toose
Texas versus New York and I understand
where Texans are coming from cuz if you
look at New York they're like it's a
people are pissing they're [__] it's
it's a mess here there's only tens of
thousands of people there how many
millions NS come through Texas forget it
so New York is getting just a little
taste of what Texas is basically saying
and why there's such objections to the
open Board of play this clip by fedman
on Twitter the clip you just pulled up a
minute ago if you can just go right
there watch this here this is Federman
by the way where you know he's the guy
that beat Dr Oz right so so here's what
he has to say about the Border listen to
him because obviously a lot of
progressives on Twitter have been
attacking you for your position on
Israel uh for noting that in your
opinion um saying that there is a crisis
at the border does not make one uh
xenophobic um why do you think you've
been so criticized by so many
progressives I I honestly don't
understand I I don't understand why it's
controversial to anybody to decide that
you're going to stand with Israel in
this situation I honestly don't
understand why it's controversial to say
we we need a secure border uh I've been
very clear in fact that was weaponized
against me as Republicans in my race
that I'm very much uh a strong supporter
of immigration and you know my my wife's
family that's the Oregon story about
that uh and I think two things can be
true at the same time you can be very
supportive immigration but we also need
to have a secure border and I really I
think about immigration is we want to
provide the American dream for any
migrant but it seems very difficult when
you have 300,000 people showing up
encountered at at our border to do that
and I think we need to to re do a reset
and we have to work together uh and
develop uh a new comprehensive solution
to that and that would also unlock a lot
of the critical aid for Ukraine again we
cannot forget about Ukraine that's
that's critical H for Israel and Taiwan
that's a very important kind of standard
that we have to maintain that we're
going to support and stand with our
allies at that are very critical I I
well first of all I think since his
stroke I don't I and I'm so happy that
he's better either the stroke made him
think straight or that's his body double
and his body doubles a Republican and
they're like what the hell which one did
we pick which one we put in front of the
camera look dude Fred you were supposed
to interview these guys that doesn't
look like the same guy that does not
look like the same guy to me you're not
listen you never know it's not the same
but it is the same guy but by the way
did you ever hear him speak like that
that's insane that that he's turned
completely he sounds like a republican
no I I I don't think there's a body
double I'm just going to I'm going to
I'm going to go with the facts here not
not not some um fantasy I think what
this guy is doing is any guy in PA
because he beat Dr Oz and Dr Oz was I
think moved from Dallas or wherever the
hell he came from um it's easy to
dismiss this guy as a weird looking
sweater wearing shorts rocking dude but
when you actually put together some of
the words that he's talking about he's
actually just using a very common sense
approach to politics and he's not
pandering to the left and he's not
basically you know going down the the
path of the right and saying hey I don't
believe in that he actually has stances
and he actually has a backbone this
guy's got a lot of issues bro he had a
stroke he has health issues he's been
it's been noted that he's dealing with
anxiety and depression and he's dealing
with all sorts of stuff but it's not
hard to say I stand with our Democrat
ratic allies in Israel it's not hard to
say a country without a border is not a
country it's not hard to say hey whether
you agree with it or not I'm not on team
Vladimir Putin these aren't
controversial statements but that where
we're at today in the woki left and the
hard right is that people are going to
say what are you talking about but
actually what he's saying is just very
common sense but you has a question
though do you think honestly Tom do you
think that in this 4 years of Biden with
this open still right now wide open is
it the damage has already been done
meaning there's no coming back from what
they've done and that was their plan all
along cuz Trump will come in okay Trump
it's going to take them years to build
the wall okay they're going to start
deporting who's had the most deportation
was it Obama how many 3 million 2
million he's the goat he's the goat the
greatest they called him the the what is
it called what they call him and chief
commander Porter and chief okay think
about this but when when Biden's done
how many illegals would would have be
here what's the project they're saying
12.99 million Arkansas another Arkansas
almost 13 million here yes okay do you
in one term in one term bananas do you
think that the damage has already been
done there's no coming back from that
because they're here even if he deports
3 million those 10 million or whatever
are going to have kids and their kids
and their kids and their kids are all
going to vote Democrat do you think it's
it's the damage is done it's a 6040
split it's a 6535 split the people that
come here from the border they're going
to vote democr at 65% of the time 65 64
65% of the time give or take yeah the
split is how's you're just increasing
but but but strategically you're
targeting a state it's the state that'll
give them victory for decades to come
that's what you're targeting you're
targeting Texas Texas it's a brilliant
dark deceptive but effective strategy
that's what you got to take that your
enemy is using a great strategy in your
face they're doing it and you're not
doing nothing about it yep well guess
what more more power to your enemy if
you're going to sit around and be okay
with it and yeah you know look what's
going on with the Border let's go water
yeah it's open okay right wide open and
you know now here's the question
becomes I can't wait if let's just say
Trump wins he comes and he deports
record-breaking amount of people out of
the state and the left goes after him
and then he says well what happened to
your hero yeah what happened to your
hero Barack Obama is he not your savior
mhm do you know he held a record for the
most people deported as a president go
all I'm doing is the catastrophic thing
your President Joe Biden did with 12.1
million give right now we're at 8 and a
half million 8 and a half and you got
how much longer left in his term
whatever another year the way it's going
right now right now we got 8 and a half
million say we end up at 10 million say
we end up at 11 12 million right they're
projecting 12, 99,000 okay you know what
Trump's going to do with that so but but
at the same time the point you're making
is yes the damage has been done
percentagewise it's not a pretty sight
so let me get to the next story here
since we've got with this quite a few
times let's go to the next one so Bernie
Sanders uh uh his wife accepted a
$106,000 book advance in 2017 she's
still working on the book this is the
leftist business uh publication Forbes
that that uh wrote this 7 years after
after receiving a six-figure advance
Jane Sanders wife of Senator Sanders is
still working on the book a community
activist a former former College
administrator accepted $106,000 book
Advance according to the Sanders
2017 tax return and a statement from her
husband's presidential campaign in 2019
set to be published by St Martin's press
which previously had released the
Senator's Memoir Jane Sanders book was
going to be about the couple's
experience together in public service a
campaign Aid told a daily mail at the
time that the payment was made public
about 7 years later it is yet to be
published but Sanders has held onto
their advance in an email to forb she
was optimistic about the project
following Bernie's book in the
presidential campaign in Co I'm
currently writing it and dare I say it's
shaping up to be quite good she expects
it to be published after the election
time you were in the publishing business
you had a company back in the days
called Premier digital publishing right
we published a book together yeah uh
doing your impossible so how long normal
after the publisher gives the author an
advance should they expect a book back
from them you're looking for your first
draft of that book with structure in
like nine months and then it usually
takes about a year as you know Pat for
editing and prep and marketing and
everything so usually about 18 months to
20 four months the book's on the market
and out there and has been sold and
you're out there talking on radio shows
about it and so to be this long I think
the problem is what the book is about it
was our successful moments in public
service and I've heard CU I talked to
somebody they wanted 10 and she's only
up to one and so she needs to find the
other nine successful moments so she can
actually complete the book I think
that's what the problem is do you really
think that's what the problem is I think
the problem is is probably excuse me I'm
going to say a word here it's probably a
piece of [__] and St Martin's press is
saying I need something different I need
something more Pat you have experience
Publishers have editors and experts that
work on this and they look at other
books that are similar they look at this
very smart and if she either hasn't
produced it or what she's produced is
unpublishable and they're going back and
forth on this it's very simple I should
get the money back the money back it's
become clear and clear and clearer to me
that uh we were all duped in 2016
because a lot of people basically were
enamored with Bernie Sanders oh the
Millionaires and the billionaires and
you know he's a great Storyteller we
talked about that but storytelling is
only a part of it you actually have to
have facts on your side and the the it's
become clear and clear that there's
Bernie Sanders there's s bankman freed
there's Bernie ma off and there's all
something uh very shammy and scammy
about all these guys and he just is
still in Congress basically running his
little scam out there but Rob pull this
up anytime that you look if you ever
want to know the difference between
where capitalism prevails and Socialism
or collectivism and communist basically
does not Prevail just look at the map of
North Korea and South Korea okay and at
night and like how much South Korea is
glowing and how much North Korea is in
the dark here right so it it's Rob
you'll find it but it the the policies
is what you have to pay attention to
yeah you see all the lights going on in
South Korea and there's no lights going
on there in North Korea that's what's
actually going on in Bernie Sanders mind
he's telling you great stories he's
telling you that there's going to the
green New Deal is going to do all this
and the wokeness and the leftest and but
but there's no facts to support any of
his nonsense yeah you know so so that
that part of the argument is great from
the business standpoint if if a company
comes and gives you money that you raise
okay they say we'll give you $100
million okay they put a timeline we want
this money back within what time three
five seven n 10 years it's called the
Redemption right and they usually put
like a five or seven year deadline
perfect a Redemption right why would a
publisher not put a Redemption right and
say hey you got three years to give me a
book you got five years to give me a
book okay you're a big name we'll give
you five years you don't need seven
years why am I giving you $116,000 for S
years because I think here's what
happens um Simon and chuster you know
Warner Brooks you know McMillan they all
compete with each other yeah and what'll
happen is they'll want a big book from
somebody that's just done something
first ladies they want the book in the
second year of their term every first
lady has a book and they're looking for
it in the second year and they all
compete so it's the word non- recoupable
and we hear at the same so it's a non-
recoupable advance so I'm giving you an
advance it'll be non- recoupable but
they fully believe that the book's going
to get there it's like Adam can talk
about he follows NBA quite a bit there's
guaranteed contracts if you get hurt or
not if you want to
resign guaranteed contract to Jane sand
that's exactly I believe that was
probably a non- recoupable advance the
same way if you want to resign a guy a
guy's in the fifth year you know what
that is he's played out his rookie
contract and now he's an All-Star option
and he's got the option so guess what
the NBA will give him a team will say
it's a $100 million com contract and 20
a year is guaranteed you know it's crazy
same thing you know what event was it
when when Sanders lost a bit of
credibility with me I mean I think he's
a True Believer him and his wife they
went to their honeymoon and Soviet Union
I mean they fully believe communism
they're not just like you know they're
they're True Believers they're all in
however they're not half what what
happened was the most incredible story
was under during his campaign when it
was done down and he was campaigning for
minimum wage should be
$15 and he was paying his workers couple
of them 13 bucks an hour and that story
came out that's when I realized the
campaign get off with this $15 an hour
stuff that you don't want to pay your
own guys I'll say one more thing about
the book dude I don't think anybody is
excited to have this book come out you
know how sometimes we'll have booking
meetings and you're like all right yeah
this person let's get this person but it
has to be this week it has to be in the
next two weeks we got to get them on
here because the story's hot right now
who gives a [__] about Bernie Sanders
much less Bernie Sanders wife right now
I think if I'm the publisher I'm just
like dude go take the money you ripped
us off by she should just make like
she's probably done one chapter cuz what
he's probably done one good thing just
make the rest pop ups so just him going
I'm like you know like like balloon hair
do something make it interesting yeah I
think I think they don't care if she
finishes the book or not they're like
you stole the money you Ponzi schemed up
congratulations have a great day all
right let's go to an uplifting story
with Joey Reed so
MSNBC Joy Reed and moms of Liberty go at
it and you just have to see this
exchange because MSNBC Joey Reid uh
criticized Tiffany Justice co-founder Ms
of Liberty over Banning the memoir all
boys aren't Blue from schools
questioning for qualifications what is
the expertise that you have and other
moms or Liberty Advocates have to decide
that a book an award-winning book isn't
appropriate for students to read Justice
responds by stating I don't have to be
an expert to know that dildos are not
appropriate for public schools okay I'm
I can read the rest of it for you but
I'll let you see the clip Rob if you
have the clip I'm I'm sure Joy Reed is
going to do a much better job than me
reading this watch this clip parents I
really want to know how are you reacting
to this exchange Rob is this the full
clip go ahead and play the clip goad and
play the clip I'm asking is what is the
expertise that you have and other moms
for Liberty Advocates have to decide
that a book an award-winning book like
all boys aren't blue isn't appropriate
for students to read what what a tragic
story of a young man who's annually
raped by his adult family member so you
have incest rape pedophilia Joy you said
you'd let me answer I'm going to answer
for you um in what context is a strapon
dildo acceptable for public school just
let I mean that's my question to you
tell me what the context around the
strap on dildo or the rape of a minor
Child by a
teacher talking about public school one
one moment all right so now you've asked
me questions I'm I'm going to answer it
well who is the main character what's
the name of the main character in all
boys AR Blue what a question ask you
just gave me very specific information
about this book so you're presenting
yourself as somebody
expert who's the main character in the
book The main character is the author
who's the what's his name George I
believe this is first because you're
giving me very specific information that
is asking to remember the name of an
author Remember speciic here's my
question talking about question you
didn't answer my question I'm going to
I'm going to answer your question great
I would love to hear that absolutely
well I I'm interviewing you and you're
not interviewing me so let's just make
sure it's a
convers what I'm saying to you is that
as you are not an expert in this book I
don't to
AR for I me is a full context story as
you said of the author's
experience why is it your right or mom's
for Liberty activists right to say that
a parent who wants their child to have
access to this book which gives a
personal experience of
this why doesn't liberal parent forance
or a parent of an lgbtq kid why don't
they have a right for their child to
just have access to this book why is it
your right to say they can't
so again we're talking about incest rape
and
pedophilia one each parent has to decide
what is appropriate for their child to
read so I want you to answer I'm going
to ask you one more time what is your
right to tell a parent who wants their
child who might feel seen by this story
why don't they have the right why don't
they have the right as a parent to say
my child can have access to this book if
a child feels seen by this story that
means that they have been uh the victim
of a predator that means that they have
either been raped by a family member
they they've experienced um and your
proof of that is what you just said that
a child feels seen by this
story you're now making assumptions
about but if a child has been raped you
should do a
lot do you okay be honest with me do you
think she's that stupid or this is the
narrative Because by the way let's not
forget who by never trust anybody that
that's hair looks like this to make any
decisions about anything about you and
your kids what she's what she's doing
right here is one of the reasons people
like me always think that the left is
always o over sexualizing kids and
doesn't care about topics like this and
that's why everybody's always like dude
they why what is she talking about what
is she even talking about and let's not
forget who Joy Reed is she's the one
member on the panel with Bill Maher when
uh Anne Coulter was like Donald Trump's
the what's it called she made that face
like she's an idiot there's no should
could think like this Tom when you hear
this logically when you hear this a a
host of a brand
MSNBC saying it's okay for a book with
dildos and pedopilia pedopilia how do
how do you process this as a prer Tom so
Joy Reid is a pathetic mouthpiece of the
left that wants to sexualize children
and wants to make sure that onboarding
and grooming materials are present at on
the shelves of librar in public schools
it's as simple as that they want the
stuff on there they want the progressive
sexualization of kids that's that's the
purpose here now I happen to think that
uh this woman could have done better for
herself I would have known the author I
would have known his date of birth I
would have known the name of the
publisher and I would have fired back at
her pretty hard on on those so I think
she could have been a little bit more
informed and kind of fought back against
it but Joy Reed's whole angle here is to
discredit her that's all she's trying to
do she was not arguing even for the book
she's just trying to discredit the other
side I'm interviewing you you're not
interviewing me meaning I'm here to ask
a bunch of questions to discredit you
but all I see is a mouthpiece for the
left to uh Advocate to putting the stuff
on the shelves in public schools to
allow kids to have access to it to act
on their Curiosities or act on their
depression that's that's her that's her
job here Adam look uh it's becoming
clear and clear who she is you know
she's going to reap what she SE I just
Googled Joy Reed just to kind kind of
see what's popping up if you Google Joy
read do it right now the first thing
that pops up is Joy read strapon so
congratulations Joy this is now the word
associated with your GOP on just just
just Joy read that's the first thing
thats Joy the second thing that pops up
is Joy readed hair and I realized where
where have I seen this hair before and
it's one of our favorite movies over
here Rob if you could pull that up we
saw her go full [__] in
Tropic Thunder we recognize that hair do
and you know they said yeah they said
you know never go full Reta rub here but
you know I also found out that Joy has
three kids and she's married I didn't I
thought she might have been a lesbian I
don't know uh but she's got three kids
so I want to know if she's going to let
her kids uh read this book I want to
know if she's encouraging her kids to
enjoy this type of Lifestyle the
youngest child that she has is 24 years
old so uh if her child was in elementary
or middle school that was what 15 years
ago before this was you know prant for
most schools to have these types of
books youngest child is 24 how old is
she Jesus anyway good for her um but uh
she's just a an absolute sh what
actually I'm actually wanting to talk
real like substance here forget about
you know you calling her idiot or shill
or this and this and that on uh uh Tom
we'll come back to Tom you sound
something awesome hang tight we'll come
to you Tom so forget about you know uh
uh what she is and you know all the name
calling the the average parent who
doesn't follow politic closely is 80% of
parents 80% of parents don't care about
politics they don't follow it they don't
turn on CNN they don't turn on Fox they
don't turn on MSNBC they don't turn
these things on maybe they get the news
as it gets a little bit closer to the
election cycle maybe a little bit but
they're watching a Netflix show at night
they're watching a series at night
they're watching watching something like
that at night you mean to tell me you're
okay with kids in school reading an
award-winning book for you know all boys
on Blue which is banned by the way go to
the top which is banned by how many
schools 29 29 school districts and you
think it's okay you know and she asked
the question in what context is a dildo
strapon acceptable and she says let that
be the decision of a parent what the
hell are you talking about what what are
you talking about by the way I'm curi
I'd love I would love the survey of you
know a
100,000 Democratic mothers who have kids
of the ages of 4 to 12 years old and ask
them what do you think about what Joy
Reed said I would be so curious to know
what percentage of them actually would
agree with Joy Reed why would I want by
the way this is not even a conversation
about the parents that are like well you
know what's wrong if you're you know
some people are born gate that's their
argument that they want to make fine go
to that argument but do you want them to
be gay there's a difference between
somebody being G you know you're
thinking you believe they were born gay
okay but do you want them to be gay some
people want their kids I they them up
that's the problem right some people
want that to be the case so why why
would you give them a book like this and
be okay with this being out there logic
is lost by the way this is going to
catch up to these guys it's going to the
one thing about content creat
ation and you being on TV and saying
what you're saying there's going to be a
lot of stuff that's going to catch up to
you that you said 5 years ago 10 years
ago 50 and you going to be like did I
really say that that what the hell what
was that all about one day people going
to sit there and say I re no I no I
there's no way in the world I would say
that a strap on dildo is okay what I
said was let the parents decide this is
nonsense what people are talking about
and this is the part of America that's a
little weird that majority of left right
Center they all agree on these topics
this is weird stop imposing this go talk
pro-life pro-choice debate that go talk
you know amount of budget for military
debate that go talk Healthcare Obamacare
debate that but this doesn't make any
sense when you imposing some like this
to me because as a parent I don't want
to hear any of this stuff in front of my
kids Tom you were going to share
something you saw about the book what
were you going to point out yeah I think
people need to know the book that their
kids are reading and you can't just take
word for it here on the description all
boys aren't blue a memoir Manifesto
manifestos are
declarations and then I look at the last
line of the description from the
publisher Johnson's emotionally Frank
style of writing will appeal directly to
young adults if you're reading this
summary here and you're not really
informed you could be mistaken into
thinking that perhaps this is a book
about trial and tribulation and that
there's something good in it and the
second paragraph both as a primer for
teens eager to be allies as well as a
reassuring testimony for young queer men
of color so that sounds like oh wait a
minute it this is a this is an engaging
book this is a sure as hell is a primer
we call it grooming and so you you read
this you got to be and teachers pick who
what teachers and award-winning who it
get the award from so you have to be so
careful in this life and you have to be
aware and I'm glad that there's a woman
willing to go on TV willing to be go
toe-to-toe with Joy Reed and to get
attacked and everything trying to get
the message out that says this
particular book and many books like it
boy parents you better why is it that
we'll read that informed parents will
read the ingredients on a bag on a bag
of potato chips but won't take time to
really look into what's really in the
books or kids are reading and Pat even
from the book publisher look at this
description at the bottom reading age 16
plus years old so they're not
recommending this fore scho children and
look at the grade level 10 to 12 that's
so why are kids even having access to it
and that's why it goes to the point
great great great observation Rob cuz I
was about to say like that's that's
recommended it's not saying that these
younger kids aren't getting it and it
goes back to the point Tom what is the
end game end goal cuz by the way Joy
Reed had all those papers that was a
planned attack on on that mother and
it's to sexualize these little kids for
futures to come because guess what then
if somebody some guy wants to get close
to them they're like oh yeah this is
this is normal get it on the Shelf baby
get it on the shelf on the Shelf yeah
this is why we always this is why we
always hear it's it's no longer
education it's indoctrination exactly
listen if you're a 17-year-old kid
you're 18-year-old kid you're a senior
junior in high school you know you're
grown up enough to do what you want to
do at that point you can drive a car you
can read a book stay the hell away from
the 10-year-olds and the sixy old by way
let me ask a question this guy George
Johnson do you think he's straight
married kids 100% gay if it's his story
he's gay
you think this guy is oh yeah that's him
oh yeah is that a turtleneck with a d
yeah he's gay zom 100% turtleneck durag
he's gay zoom in right there Rob can you
zoom in not that there's anything wrong
with that V to the top no I'm just
saying right there uh all the way at the
top he's a queer
African-American best known as the
author of The Memoir Manifesto all boys
aren't blue okay did it say 16 plus yeah
it said 16 you know how they have that
in the movies the PG
nc7 they should have the exact same
thing for books way 10-year-old kid
should not be reading this book by the
way I I'm not bashing this guy like who
knows maybe the stuff that he went
through confused him and made him it has
nothing against him guess what if you
want to read that book fine but why is
there any access to somebody that's you
know 6 years old s years old there's no
explanation and joy like the only reason
they can't fire Joy Joy Reed is because
she checks all the boxes they can't fire
her so by the way you know for the
people that are listening you're like
look man just stop with this woke stuff
just stop with this you know fear porn
with par nothing is really going on like
what's wrong with this all boys are not
blue or whatever okay so tell me this is
a little bit weird Washington State
Democrats proposed replacing the term
sex offender to advance a person first
approach so which means is a bill House
Bill 2177 to replace the term sex
offender with uh uh sex offense in the
sex offender policy this change aims to
shift uh towards a person first approach
which to build allowing level three sex
offenders the most dangerous to serve on
the board alongside six Crime Victims
let let me read this to you again please
which means a level three sex offenders
okay allowing this bill allows level
three sex offenders The Most Dangerous
Ones to serve on the board alongside sex
Crime Victims okay State represent Terra
s a Democrat and former felon
supports the bill believing that sex
offenders have invaluable information to
share sopb chair Brad maryu also backs
The Proposal welcoming the inclusion of
voice that provide a reality check in
public policy Republican state
representative Dan griffy opposes the
measure questioning why the board should
have a convicted sex offender as a
member the bill follows previous efforts
in Washington to release sexually
violent predators and place them in less
restrictive uh alternative near Child
Care Facilities Tom like is this like a
so so by the way again you read this and
you say are these guys serious Tom what
are your thoughts on this I I I these
legislatures in in in Washington state
have just lost their freaking mind
there's no sense there's no sense of
logic in this there's no sense sense of
you you you read this and you say
where's the logic okay you say okay even
though I disagree with him where's he
coming from and what does he think is
really going to happen you know there
are a lot of things it's like um the
treasury Department worked with
counterfeits there's a whole movie Catch
Me If You Can that talks about how the
treasury Department Frank abale yeah
took a guy who was a counterfeit and a
and a and a financial felon and he
eventually consulted you know he got his
life clean he got he had to get clean he
had no way to be employed to do anything
and he told them this is how these
crimes are committed this and it was
incredibly helpful and it create banking
security things there's one thing to do
that to take uh criminals who are
demonstrated um that they have been you
know um I don't want to say healed but
they def they got their life together
and stuff and they come back and say hey
here's your leaks in the system where
you know people like what I used to do
where we can get access to to your kids
that's helpful not on the board serving
on the board and not in a less
restrictive alternative near a child
care facility near a child care facility
are you kidding me I I I don't
understand it I'm just trying to find
the logic in this and it's just state
representative Tara Simmons a Democrat
and former felon hey look there's hope
for Trump to be elected you know it's
the so she's a former felon supporting
the bill so I what I see here I see just
a lack of logic you can use former
criminals to help you find leaks and to
make things safe and change in the
future you can do that but putting them
on the board and then giving them you
know actual access this to me is just
lunacy Adam yeah I mean I you uh took
the words my right out of my mouth I I
actually had the pleasure of meeting
Frank Abell um at a meeting um uh
handful of years ago if you're not
familiar with who this guy is Leonardo
DiCaprio played him and Catch Me If You
Can and and he told his story about
basically running away as a teenager and
uh check fraud and wire fraud and cash
and checks and did all this and he knew
the ins and outs of what it was to do
money laundering and check fraud and
everything like that and then Tom Hanks
in the movie basically Catch Me If You
Can tried to catch him and there was
that whole cat and mouse game but
basically he ended up becoming an
informant for the FBI um and we've seen
this a million times with the mafia
people basically informing and you know
we we don't want to go down that path
understand like that we've also seen
people like former Isis members that
come out and basically inform
levelheaded democracies this is what's
going on over there so that's you know
if I can just try to spin this in a
positive light which is very hard to do
in this situation that's what I'd like
to believe is happening here hey here's
how us sickos think hey here's how house
weirdos are looking for because we saw
the the sound of freedom we we know
what's going on so if we can utilize
these sickos to help catch more sickos
great but some of these stories are not
adding up right here and I I think
change I think anytime that they they
like to replace terms to me like
updating terms like pedophile they
change it to minor attractive person
you're a pedophile stop trying to soften
the language cuz when you soften the
language it doesn't make the the act any
any less crazy like you're a ped
cuz when I hear map I'm like oh it's
just a map that's no that's no no you're
a pedophile and you have to be separated
from society I'm sick and tired of the
language changing CU that's that's the
problem the culture changes the language
but the act the person is still there
and they shouldn't be in the public well
it's again it all comes down to not
hurting people's feelings despite the
fact that they're freaking pedophiles I
don't give a [__] about your feeling
pedopile you belong in jail for we just
saw we did a story two weeks ago that uh
fat people they're getting too fre three
seats on a plane because they're no
longer obese they're persons of size so
they don't want to offend the fat people
out there make them pay when you worry
about terms you're back to worry about
feelings the point Adam made about
feelings about 15 minutes ago and he's
absolutely right you know you're not a
thief you're a non- permission borrower
I mean what are we going to do are we
going to take everything that we have
because we have feelings we don't like
the way the term feels well look if you
don't like the way what do they teach
you you know I've been part of um um you
know uh I'm G to say this carefully I've
been part of recovery sessions where I
was invited to come support someone who
is in recovery and one of the first
things they teach you is to not soften
it and at the beginning of these
sessions I sat in this kind of this back
row and they all walk in they stood up
and they stated their name and they say
I am an alcoholic and then they sit down
and then I one of the guys stood up and
he said I am an alcoholic and I
seriously have injured the relationships
in my family and he sat down he
apparently he's not supposed to or
doesn't have to say the other part of it
but he said it bluntly why because he
wanted to accept oh responsibility and
accountability for what he was and he's
there in a group to get encouragement to
go forward and if we turn this into
feelings oh that feels bad oh that feels
bad then really what you're doing is
you're just moving accountability off of
the person who has done things in
society called criminals whether it's a
misdemeanor or a felon you create you
committed a crime and and you're you're
softening it and you're just taking the
accountability out of society great
Point Tom so let's go to the next story
Goldman shrien shrien sees four rate
Cuts uh 2% inflation for
2024 uh he predicts the Federal Reserve
were lower interest rates four times in
2024 starting in March and that
inflation will reach the central bank's
2% Target he also expects European
Central Bank and Bank of England to
follow suit but the bank of Japan to
raise rates in April April he advises
investors to look for opportunities in
Emerging Markets such as turkey and
recommends Chinese stocks as a
contrarian by after the local Benchmark
hits pandemic lows he believes that the
first half of 2024 will be marked by
choppy range-bound markets as markets
react to the timing and the PES of Fed
rate Cuts even though risky assets are
expected to perform well throughout the
year he also predicts that the FED will
modify its inflation Target to R of 1
and A2 to 22% once the 2% Target is
achieved and the next move in US yields
will likely be upward Tom so what we're
hearing from Goldman Sachs is basically
um shiffrin and shiffrin uh I don't say
I like Joshua because I don't really
know him but I've read a lot of his
stuff and he tends to be a pretty level
head and a pretty long long range uh
thinker and so through that lens I
usually read what he's writing with some
interest and what's interesting here is
I also balance out what we're hearing
from the FED fed Board of Governors
people have been saying and you may have
heard this uh well we think that rates
may have to be higher longer and they're
not saying how many you know what I mean
Pat but you've heard the phrase higher
longer and what that means is that
they're probably going to go longer
before they reduce it and that's right
in line and why he's interpreting this
to say hey the feds said six rate cuts
and it was goes back to like November
they said they foresaw six rate Cuts in
2024 they haven't repeated that that
hasn't been repeated a lot um they've
been now going to hire longer and I
think what he's pointing out is that you
can take a look at the Dow and although
Main Street and um Wall Street are not
together you're seeing an economy that
is really trying to drive a little bit
um we've got good news and bad news on
consumer spending on not just the
spending but how they're paying for it
and so you inflation is being a little
stubborn right now it's not at 2% it's
down lower certain Commodities like
gasoline are lower which is a break
heating oil is a little lower right now
which is a bit of a break although the
Middle East could raise that up and what
he I think is pointing out is that hey
Point number one I think rates are going
to be higher longer Point number two I
only think there's going to be four rate
Cuts next year which means if you're
dreaming about a 4.75% mortgage next
year that mean this year 24 uh-uh not
going to happen happen and but it'll
break six oh I think yeah I think it'll
break I think I think we'll see 575 at
the end of the year it's a whole another
discussion I don't want to dive into but
I'll just give you two headlines right
now the banks are keeping about a 3%
profit on the Fed rate to the mortgage
rate and you can see that represented by
the 10year treasury that's the way to
look at it they usually have that about
one and a half to two means the banks
right now want to make more profits on
mortgages because they think they will
be lower in the future but they're not
going to get back down to like a a real
what I would call a consumer activity
trigger rate which would be like
475 Adam well no the the the one
question that Vinnie always asks is
when's a good time to buy when's a good
time to buy I was just gonna say that so
uh to all the people out there in the
mortgage Market we see the the Articles
out there from The Wall Street Journal
that there's never been a worse time to
buy and the math just doesn't add up so
if you're in the market to buy a a house
just pay attention to what's going on
there with the interest rates you know
you for all the for all that we hear
about politics and Trump and Biden and
Des santis and Nikki Haley and Gavin and
Nome lowkey the most important person in
America is Jerome pal I mean this is the
guy that makes unemployment tick and
make interest rates tick and inflation
and all this fun stuff so pay attention
to what's going on with this guy Jerome
pal but it's good news for the people
who are looking to buy houses or maybe
refinance their house that these
interest rates potentially in 2024 are
going to be coming down you're a veteran
I'm a veteran every veteran out there
has a one time low very low interest
rate for for a house I think the money
went up to what I think 700 pbd you got
to utilize that one of thing I would
have used it for so my question is to
you if if like for instance like put me
and and for all the Vets out there God
bless you thank you guys for your
service um what does it matter if you
have that onetime low interest rate to
buy a house and that this doesn't affect
us you know what I mean what do you mean
so like right now cuz that this rate
well we if I want a loan right now for a
house because I'm a veteran I get a time
it's rid I don't think it's a low
interest rate I think it's a low down
payment you have to put 3% down they're
just giving you a free a very low
veterans get a uh a low interest rate is
this for for one time first time vas for
a veteran I know I know it's
ridiculously low I think this is it I
don't think it's a set number that's
never going to change I think it's just
lower than what others would be paying
okay if I'm not mistaking on the
interest rates above show the options of
purchasing discount account 1.1%
yeah so I think I think even if you look
at this chart here for 30 you're fixed
yeah you're looking at 6% you're you're
getting 1% off and this is a buy down if
you look read the fine print you're
actually buying down the rate and and uh
and Rob can you say if this is this the
first time the first time I'm not saying
in general I'm talking about the first
time your first loan for I don't know
I'm glad I'm really glad that we're
doing a real estate mortgage
intervention for Vinnie right now on air
on camera this is working out well let's
look into this later Vin but don't buy
house right now wait for the rates to
come down I'm moving in with you and
your
cats your cats all right buy our pay
later holiday dead hangover has arrived
as consumers wonder how they'll pay pay
their bills many Americans turn to buy
and out pay later Kiki Anderson one of
what a great name Kiki Anderson one such
consumer use Clara Clara and PayPal to
make purchases resulting in $1700 in
debt leading her to sell items to make
payments why'd you buy it in the first
place buy out pay later surge uh uh use
it surge during holiday season
contributing to $16.6 billion to online
spending with a 43% Spike on Cyber
Monday however concerns arise about
consumers being B buried under micro
payments the impact of buy not pay later
and overall debt remains unclear due to
limited disclosure from providers like
clarina PayPal affirm uh Tom how how bad
is it based on the numbers you're seeing
well I I want Adam's opinion as well but
it's pretty bad what I'm reading was
that they didn't put it in the CNBC
story they are
40% uh uh late payment rates on these on
the bnpl 40% late payment and that came
out the first week of January which
means from Black Friday through holiday
spending suddenly because remember these
bills are due two weeks later two weeks
later you make a payment two weeks later
make a payment two weeks later make a
payment they don't they these have a a
very short leash um leash is a sensitive
W this
weekens a good friend in Las Vegas I
won't use that word in front of him I
promise um the so it's 40% late payment
rates on this why and why did they use
it they use it because they they ran the
credit cards in this country all the way
up to 1 trillion of total balances so
the consumer was looking for some more
credit to go purchase and they use buy
now pay later they were already a little
strapped and guess what 40% of them are
late and so the they're calling it a
debt hangover it's not a debt hangover
it's a debt overextension mhm Adam nice
well one thing they forgot to add one
line to this to the uh buy now pay later
thing and then it's buy now pay later
you're broke after that because if you
don't have the money to pay for
something now if you think that you're
going to somehow manifest the money two
weeks later that you don't have you're
in for a slippery slope and you're in
for basically what happens when we go to
people like like Amscott and you go for
these payday loans and next thing you
know you're paying 400% on your money
short-term thinking will end end up with
long-term problems you think that you
can just start spending your way out of
the holidays buy some knife kits for the
family and all of a sudden you're going
to have a money just show up at your
doorstep in January it doesn't work that
way and can we just talk about the
fictitious holidays that we're just
making up at this point for people to
spend money I get it you want to spend
money on Christmas cool you want to
spend money on New Year's I get it
Valentine's Day Thanksgiving family but
they're just making up holidays for us
to spend money on okay it's Cyber Monday
it's black Thursday and it's what's the
Tuesday one now you know have a party on
Tuesday there's small business
Saturday they're just making up days for
us to spend money and they're
encouraging us you don't need money
you'll pay us back later with 400%
interest that is so it's a disaster out
there as I always say save that money
you know that's why you know I don't you
guys always ask how come I don't
participate in cyber Mondays or black
Fridays I'm waiting for like like a
brown Thursday there's no you
know why can't we get
something Thursday Brown Thursday Brown
Thursday every give you TV I have the
santis map of San Francisco it looks
like every day is brown day so that's a
different kind of a anyway shout out to
Kik Anderson learning the hard Kiki do
you love me yeah uh more single women
are buying homes Yahoo finance a report
from Maxwell indicates that single women
uh uh 22 constitute uh uh constitute
22% of mortgage applications in
2023 with 35% of these applications ages
25 to 34 and many earning less than
$100,000 annual the rise of single woman
in the housing market suggests a shift
in demographic with Millennials and genz
showing interest in home ownership many
women are willing to relocate for more
affordable housing options emphasizing
their commitment to building Equity
factors such as increase female
participation labor force and a growing
number of households led by women
contribute to this trend each woman and
long-term relationships are opting for
Sol home ownership often because they
earn more than their partners by the way
more single women buying homes it's not
because more single women are buying
homes it's because there are more single
women today than before because marriage
is not a hot commodity today on the same
uh uh story that we have here at the
bottom you hear this other one says
childless future birth rate plunging as
Millen decide against being parents
right so this isn't just because single
women are buying homes they're not
wanting to get married those numbers are
higher today they don't want to have
kids it's higher today let me read the
study to you study by the University of
South Hampton and the generation of
gender program found that less than a
fifth of Millennials ages 26 to 35 are
certain they want to become parents the
study reveals a correlation with
declining birth rates as only 19% of
younger Millennials expressed a
definitive desire to have children while
30% leaned towards probably wanting
children the desire of children among
Generation Z ages 18 to 24 is also
declining compared to previous
generations 15% of gen Z respondents
stated that they definitely do not want
children suggesting that the birth rate
in UK may continue to decrease the study
also highlights that the high cost of
child care and parents typically
spending an average of $711 per month on
child child care for more for lower
income household child care expenses can
account 20 to 30% of their income so one
single woman buying homes because they
don't want to get married and more
people more younger generation don't
want to have kids Tom what do you see
here with these numbers well first of
all if you're a single woman with a home
and you're looking for a patriotic
stable husband this morning I signed an
agreement I'm representing Vinnie you
can find him on manck and for $25 you
could ask a question and begin an
interview process that could end in a
fruitful relationship again women with
homes please find vinia manck what I
think here I think it's a it's a little
bit of a BS uh headline I think you
called it there because there's more
there are more women that are single and
not married than now and what has
happened now is we've become we've kind
of devalued the long-term relationship
is what we've done and when you devalue
the long-term relationship people aren
getting married and when you and when
they see all the issues and the ense of
having kids some people make a rational
what they think is they don't realize
the joy you can have having kids and and
what you're actually bringing to society
yes kids are expensive but you you know
what you know generational creation
actually makes a better stronger society
and I think they see all the expense and
they see all of the the they're in this
mindset of like short-term hookup
culture and you have people that don't
value long-term relationships and think
of kids as just a pure expense and then
you're screaming in their ear that you
know that you know you should do what
you want to do be who you want to be and
do all this none of that speaks to hey
what about leading and serving and
giving yourself to other human beings in
a family listen just manck me lady
single let's have a kid it's crunch time
with a house with a house I say this all
the time uh if there's anybody I want
commenting on modern-day hookup culture
it's Tom Ellsworth the P do nobody
understands what it's like to be out in
these streets in these clubs and These
Bars like Tom and that's why I love
about you Tom so TBD you okay man good I
mean the truth hurts here guys but Tom
great breakdown but but Tom to be
genuine that's the kind of guy you
actually probably want to mirror your
life around because he's actually a
grownup man with kids Vinnie I pray for
that for yourself and for for you too
for me as well but the you this story it
seems heart warming on the surface off
um single women are buying homes that's
great but let me tell you what happens
ladies you're going to be 35 years old
you move into your new house you're
going to be all set up you're going to
be going on and then you're going to set
up all the stuff around the house you
got to put stuff together you're going
to need some Nails you're going to need
some uh hammers you're going to need
some screwdrivers and there's going to
be no dude there to help you out so I
don't think that's the type of LIF stuff
you want if you want that Chelsea
Handler lifestyle wake up every day
you're 48 years old you got no kids you
got 17 dildos and you just going to town
on yourself with some perco setes and
some vodka sign up for the Chelsea
Handler mortgage it's only 7% right now
and it's going to last you the rest of
your life of miserableness so the
breakdown of traditional families the
breakdown of Traditional Values is
basically what we're seeing uh seep into
America and for the people out there
that's like what do you mean uh man you
and Vinnie you're in your 40s and you're
single well news flash women can't have
kids after 40 for the most part alpacino
just had a kid when he's freaking 82 the
math don't add up it's a little bit
different so you know slide into
Vinnie's man DM slide into my man DM
gentlemen if you need some coaching with
that but there there's no way that that
this this is going to be a happy ending
for a lot of these women that move into
their houses but Vinnie but maybe that
we can reverse the roles so if you wake
if you if you're with you move in with
this girl and you guys break up you can
sue her and take half her [__] like
happens to 98% of men when they go
through a divorce Alo so try that out
how old was alucino he had a baby 83 you
think when he had orgasms he goes H well
at that age it's like H yeah but it's
it's I think that every I'm just getting
warmed up I'm getting warmed up I think
that and this is the pbds credit BL pill
every single one of us needs to
transition at one point to being selfish
to self less and women have to make that
move quicker than men men can hold out a
little bit longer but I say the same
thing that my buddies were 40 somewhere
almost approaching 50 guys you can't be
out here still you know all up in the
club but and there's nothing sadder than
when I see a 44y old woman still out in
the club and I knew her from high school
I'm like just go home get out of here
get out of here ha all right couple
stories left then I will wrap up Biden
doj finally admits Hunter Biden's laptop
is real and and this is uh so funny yeah
it is funny but Ian we're making
progress guys we're making progress the
justice department has officially
confirmed the authenticity of Hunter
Biden's laptop a development that comes
after years of suppressing this
information doj's acknowledgement is
based on the laptop being left at a
computer store and its contents matching
what investigators obtained via search
warrant at Hunter's iCloud the laptop
from Hell story initially reported by
the New York Post fa significant denial
and discrediting by the media with the
CNN The Washington Post New York Times
eventually acknowledging its
authenticity in an interview with the
White House and Means Committee IRS
supervisory criminal investigative agent
Gary shapley a whistleblower revealed
that FBI extensively analyzed the laptop
and federal prosecutors expressed
confidence that it was indeed hter
Biden's laptop that had not been
manipulated shapely affirmed it was a
reliable evidence Tom so I look this is
one let's connect the dots the media has
been Unleashed in the last 6 months to
write stories that were critical of Joe
Biden his capabilities his mental acuity
we've seen it and these are top tier
Frontline mainstream media writing
stories check Obama attempts to talk to
Biden right before Christmas to
strategize about you got to get serious
about this you should get my my boy
David paff involved you should get some
folks in here from my campaign to help
you out apparent ly Biden's people said
NOP don't want to do that Obama circled
back again as The Story Goes and said
look you got people at the White House
and you got people 100 miles away in
Virginia that are trying to run this
campaign you're disconnected apparently
Biden said Thank you Barack we got this
and what did Obama do leaked it to the
media the mainstream media had the same
article the same story in unison what
does that have to do with the laptop
well guess what the next data point
comes out the doj this is Biden they
call it Biden's doj but it's basically
the doj that's sort of divorcing itself
from Biden and saying yeah you know all
that stuff yeah it was a reliable
evidence and it was pictures a young
girl picture of him snorton and a couple
emails where he actually referenced uh
getting his dad you know the president
involved and uh getting kickbacks from
foreign governments for fake Consulting
with energy companies yeah it was real
yeah well guess what this is a this is
the perfect and again you have to tip
your hat to the left the Democrats these
cats play to win and they have a great
Playbook okay they have not only have
the F with this story they have the FBI
go there to to Twitter shut down every
single story okay and then four years
later this is what they want they wanted
to drag it on so long that now when we
hear it we're like we're over it
everybody's like no it's not that we're
over it it's what's next follow the
follow the
breadcrumbs I'm saying is though when
this came out do you know when this
would have been hot which would have
changed voters idea idea on on who to
vote for was during the election so what
I'm saying is right now even right now
while you read that I went are we still
talking about it like it's I'm I'm
personally tired of it I know it's real
I know what he did on it I know about
the drugs I know about the cocaine and
the underage looking follow the
breadcrumbs when is that story when is
that story that article came out the 51
or can you zoom out so I can see who the
logo is at the top uh this is from
Politico this is from political saying
that it's so funny and this is from
October 19th of 2020 when 50 former
senior intelligence officials signed a
letter election correct that the hunter
Biden laptop was Russian disinformation
but they're brilliant though but Tom do
you feel like do you understand what
they do senior by the way senior in
heads the top I I didn't realize that
there was an an argument over whether
the laptop actually existed what do you
mean they said it's fake I want to I
thought the I thought the argument was
what's in correct the laptop so
basically
existence of a laptop plural there but
we had what's his name John Paul Mac
Isaac the the half blind guy that was
here he said I touched it I felt it I
can't see half the [__] but I have it by
the way his house got swatted the other
day by the Delaware PD this friend right
here he has crazy eyes where he can see
Tom at the same time blind Vinnie no
he's not he wasn't blind he was looking
at
Tom when you see laptop when you see the
word laptop substitute it your mind
election deception tool and so in 2020
the laptop was an election deception
tool two weeks before so that they could
basically manipulate the election toward
Biden against Trump now they're using
the election deception tool to prepare
for the movement of Biden aside Adam
don't start yelling I'm going there
again um and now the question is what do
you do with it this basically all but
guarantee
you need to Pardon Hunter and it also
means if you're pardoning Hunter and you
have all the stuff in there that was
very incriminatory about Biden and the
family members actually taking the money
how do you pardon Biden if you lose the
election you can't pardon Biden if Gavin
Nome wins the election and the deal is
PID him pardon him on the first day damn
well you better win that election right
of course how do you pardon Biden that's
a good that's a great point I believe
believe that not only do you have to say
um you know um at the convention
there'll be some guys back backstage who
throw a bunch of bags down the stairs
okay oh my gosh did you hear that Biden
is falling downstairs we need a new
candidate so they're going to architect
something at the convention right he
slipped and fell in the in the shower
whatever it is or for the good of the
company for the good of country I've
decided to step aside step aside and I
will allow someone else to be here
however they architect that and I think
it's happening at the convention now the
question is how do you pardon Biden I
think he has to resign and you got to
get kamla to do it for one day but then
my question would be if I was kamla
Harris that's got a big old price tag on
it okay wait wait wait wait wait so
you're pushing me aside I'm out I'm not
going to run she's got negos she wants
to run and you're going to set aside for
one day and you want me to Pardon him
for one day so I get to be the first
female president for one day and I'm I'm
going to Pardon him says you got to put
a couple more zeros on that of course so
my question is in all this follow the
breadcrumbs it is steadily leading to
Biden is out and it's very steadily
leading to that look at the just look at
the bread crims that are in plain sight
that are being leaked by the left and he
can pardon his family but he can't
pardon himself they basically reminded
Donald Trump that you can't pardon
yourself remember how loud they yelled
you can't pardon yourself on the last
day out of here you can't do that well
how do you pardon Biden because he now
he's incriminated in this when you say
the laptop's real then you say kickbacks
from foreign governments are real and so
how do you pardon yourself he's go to
and he's he's got to step aside for one
day Tom I'm goingon to ask you the
question I asked Vinnie all the time uh
you want to
bet I don't think look everyone has this
speculation that Michelle Michelle
Obama's coming to rescue this that KLA
Harris is goingon to be president for a
day it's becoming clear and clear and
clearer it's Trump versus Biden whether
you like it or not the the the election
nobody in the country wants to see I
don't but it's happening I do not think
at all that Joe B how much you want to
bet I'm not saying that I'm advocating
for Joe Biden but we're all coming up
with these Gavin Newsome conspiracy
theories and all of a sudden Michelle
Obama is going to take whip her dick out
and become the president you said I'm
just saying brother it's clearly but can
I ask you a question though can I ask
you a question it's Biden versus Trump
so you think at like you think in one
year on a debate stage Donald Trump with
Joe Biden is going to happen are you
absolutely out of your mind besides the
fact I don't think he's going to
physically mentally be talk is cheap put
your money where your mouth is hold on
one second I'm not saying I'm looking
forward to it I'm saying that is what is
far more likely to happen pull up the
presidential odds right now just look at
the numbers guys this guy thinks that
he's going to drop out of the race and
president he's going he's going to do
all this nonsense I want to ask him Rob
and follow the do you three do you three
think it's going to come down Joe Biden
against him I'm just curious do you
think by the way look at where Michelle
has come up it's still 12 to one it
doesn't matter that's a lot different
from one to one yeah but by the way
Michelle wasn't even in the top 30 6
months ago FYI Adam numbers guy she was
all the way at the freaking bottom with
Oprah look at where her ass is right now
right behind your boy with less than
your way so stop talking about it and be
about it put your money where your mouth
is your then your talk is cheap you're
my friend you don't want to take my
money I'll gladly take your money Vin
can I ask you one question I I'm there's
no emotion I'm just saying look at the
numbers do you think it's going to be B
just no betting do you think it's going
to be Joe Biden to go against him when
Biden's he just asked him a question
hold on hold on I want to ask you too
and you too Rob just do you think it's
going to be Joe Biden versus Trump when
it comes down to it I think here's
here's how I process that if if no one's
ever gotten reelected being in the third
30s okay and Democrats are not uh you
know going to sit there and just be like
yeah listen let's take this L I don't
think that's the kind of a party they
are I don't think they're going to just
take an l and say guys you know like
this morning Josh Allen was being
interviewed not this morning they after
they lost the quarterback yeah the
quarterback from Buffalo Bill so you
know how's it feel now that it's real at
least I'm alive at least I have another
day right which you kind of trying to
you know play it out and you heard
Giannis when he lost and the guy asked a
question do you see the season as a
failure andanas loses and gives an
answer um I don't think thems are going
to let an easy victory for Trump
especially Trump okay think about the
Republicans that have won in the past
and how much they hated them Bush was
the Antichrist right you go to senior
you go to Reagan they really hated you
know some of these guys the level of
hate they got for Trump it's nowhere
near to any of the candidates they've
ever had okay so do I think they're
gonna
let Biden be the candidate it's one of
the worst decisions they will ever make
if they do that one of the worst
decisions they'll ever make so for me to
sit there and take his argument and say
I'm telling you this is what's going to
happen I understand his logic because
what month are we January we got what 10
months left less than 10 months left
nine and a half months left I get what
he's saying but also at the same time
man I I don't know why I'm convinced the
the I've said this the hardest part
they're going to have is Camala Harris
Camala Harris how do you get her to set
aside you have to give her something for
her to sit aside without complaining
bitching and whining and you can't
replace her with a white guy Trump's
going to run with that Republicans are
going to run with that they put another
woman in the back of the bus so all the
progress Democrats were talking about 60
years of wasted you know boom out the
window right Cala go s in the back of
the bus the first thing you'll see is a
picture a meme with Cala Harris in the
back of the bus and you know who's going
to post that picture Donald Trump Jr and
Donald Trump are going to post it and
then everybody else from the magga camp
is going to share that because it's
going to be funny to share it's going to
make sense so no I think the argument
with the Kamala is if they lead with
Michelle as president and they lead with
Nome as VP it's a phenomenal
forgiveness of Kamala sitting down and
saying okay that makes sense I think
that's the only way where the Democratic
vote is not going to do that but the
Wright is still going to be able to say
no you still sat down to VP and replace
it with Nome so maybe it's going to be
Nome the lead and Michelle VP and the
reason why Michelle wants to be VP is
because she want she does not want any
of the job or nothing to do she's a
great promoter she'll go around talking
about how amazing G Gavin Nome is and
how much he's done for the states and
how great of his thing that's the card
they're going to play but if they just
go with Joe Adam my biggest challenges
if they just go with with
Joe you're
losing nine out of 10 times on many of
these polls so why would they do that I
don't see Dems just taking an l and
saying this is a lost cause I I fully
agree with your perspective right here
and this political jockeying
every every angle you turn all right if
Joe doesn't go then we're going to have
Cala run but we don't want Kamala but
all right so we're going to put Michelle
there and then it's going to be Michelle
and then kamla but then there's two
black women running for president that's
not going to happen oh my God that's
never no woman's been elected okay so
then we're going to have Gavin Nome come
in and he's going to be our savior but
everyone knows that Gavin Newsome like
all these jocking I I just look at the
facts in front of my face they're they
are looking at a they're running into a
buz saw with Trump and they're just
having seen out old Joe Biden at the
front of the bus and they're hoping and
they're praying and they're wishing that
all right America we're going to do it
again and we're just going to convince
everybody that Trump is a threat to
democracy and he's racist and they're
going to try to do that and it's likely
to fail but he's the guy the only reason
he won in 2020 Adam is because by the
way Co he's the bag no I don't care if
Jesus chist was in but that and
suppressing stories with the FBI to
think hold on so to think right now with
this fouryear track record which is
keeps getting worse that they're going
to both walk in and Biden has any chance
you're you're going to I'm not I'm not
saying he has a chance I'm saying he's
going to be running Charlamagne the God
says Biden has never been a good
candidate was elected due to Unfortunate
Events Charlemagne asserted that Biden's
dismal polling is due to how he's never
been a good candidate and was elected
for you know Series of Unfortunate
Events charlam expresses concerns about
Biden's messaging and his ability to
inspire voters saying their messaging
sucks even though they have accomplished
some good things while they've been in a
White House nobody knows that nobody
wants party
uh nobody want to party with Joe Biden
he's just not inspiring in any way shape
or form maybe he needs to find a little
bit of that Obama Bill Clinton energy to
inspire he's not going to find it guys
charl emphasize the importance of
presidential candidates addressing
issues related to upwardly Mobility
saying how can you put money in people's
pockets because that you know gives
people a sense of security and that is
what the candidates should be focusing
on if all of a sudden the Dems did flip
in August and they put a new
uh Michelle combination do you know what
mainstream media would do with that CNN
what Jimmy Fallon coob Bear all these
podcasts the Oprah Winfrey the NBA
LeBron theet it do you know what Taylor
Swift do you know what these guys would
be
doing it would be Bonkers by the way if
it is Michelle and Nome it's going to be
a dog fight I'm if it is Michelle and
Nome it's going to be a dog fight and uh
in that okay let me ask this question
the the literal chance that you don't
think it's going to be Biden what's your
chance 1% 5% no it's higher than that
like like I'm I'm in 0% defending Joe
Biden as a good candidate I think he's a
freaking disaster but I think they're
ready to for the disaster what do you
think is a percentage of it being
somebody else than him uh 10% okay that
10% of the 10% that you believe what are
the chances that the new president VP
candidate one of them is going to be a
female oh yeah very very very very high
99% okay what are the chances one of the
two is going to be
black yeah higher higher than the 99
yeah then who's left
yeah you got KLA you got Michelle okay
perfect so now we have Michelle and
who's a better option Michelle or camalo
it's not even close it's not even so if
it's a president that they replace Obama
who would that person be that's at the
top so you got Nome some people flirted
with the name mark cubin That's why Mark
sold his team and T and okay so say so
so say it is a Nome and a Michelle
okay on the Trump side how important is
it for Trump to choose a VP that's a
female somewhat important not overly
import give me the
percentage uh in terms of importance the
percentage chances of trump and a female
as a VP 30% 60% oh you're putting that
high I put 30 I say more than better
than average Tom where are you at with
Tom's V his vpb know a female I think
it's a
25% chance that he will but it's a 75%
chance that he should oh interesting
answer okay fair then if that's the case
who are the candidat stefanic female
Tulsi female right L uh maybe Lake both
both very capable up in
uh like but yeah my challenge is my I
think my challenge with choosing a VP is
somebody that's very much like you okay
if you choose a VP that's like you yeah
Christin South Dakota right it's too
much like you if it's like you then
there there there has to be an element
of that person being different than you
to be able to compete but if it is a NSA
Michelle and it's a trump whoever oh my
gosh every day it's going to be a fight
yep every day from August September
October no that three months every
single it's not even three months it's
two and a half months those two and a
half months every single day is going to
be a fight I'm with you 100% And I'm not
trying to argue with um with Adam and
Vinnie on the previous point I'm just
pointing out that when the department of
effing
Justice validates the laptop it's
basically you're validating
demonstratively impeachable evidence so
let's say they Rigg the event the
election and Biden wins the the anger
that will be on the Republican side and
they will take this thing and they will
shove it up his ass and they will
impeach him that's how big but that's
under the assumption that there's
something in there that is incriminating
Joe Biden there's there's a lot of stuff
to incriminate Hunter no doubt that
guy's yeah but first class they have not
been able to make anything stick well
they can't because he runs the the
department hearings and there there are
four different groups four different
groups Adam that have started that have
all of the impeachment structures in
place four groups of congressmen that
are ready to start hearings but they
haven't and the answer is why and what
are they doing it has to do with the
election it has to do with distraction
and it has to do that I don't think they
need they they think they need they have
to we know where the impeachment are
going that happened with Trump if you
hold the Senate if you hold the house
nothing Happ I'm going to shut up but
yes or no does it change things when the
Department of Justice validates the
contents of the laptop of course it does
thank you they have to admit it but then
but just really and then you have to go
you have to go down the what now now
path not speculating not conspiracy but
it leads to where it leads me is Joe
Biden is done that's where it leads me
and it just a matter I could speculate
all day long how you know what I think I
think it'll be done at the convention
but I'm with Pat They I don't think they
have any choice I don't think they're
going to take the L and I think they're
going to put things up and it is going
to be
one of the most important and crazy 60
days in American history between August
21st and November just to be clear do I
think they should have made this change
a year ago yes do I think that this that
that Biden is going to be running into a
trump buzs saw where people are like
yeah we're going to give Trump another
shot 100% do I also think they're going
to double down and go down with the ship
yes no wow you can't do that that
because I no I I that La okay where are
where are you at with the chance of all
of those things you said the last one
that they're just going to keep running
take the one thing that you guys have to
just keep in mind is that it's not just
hey switch the candidates it's all the
Dirty Work behind the scenes the
Grassroots the campaign the getting them
on the ballots the infrastructure the
DNC there's so much stuff behind the
scenes that has to happen that it's just
not just like all right uh Biden you're
out uh Gavin you're Michelle you're in
there's so much stuff going on behind
the scenes and we'd be hearing stories
coming from the DNC we'd be hearing
stories coming from the call coming
inside the house saying oh yeah they're
already setting stuff up bro they're
already happening none of those stories
are coming out listen let's just assume
Adam that they're not they don't have to
announce nothing because we know that
these cats are disgustingly dirty
tricksters the left is they'll stop at
nothing to win and keep that power
border everything like that who knows
even if they were going to have an
election let's say God forbid there's a
power outage with all the Leave the
World Behind speaking of the Obamas but
let's go back to Charlamagne the god Mr
Mr um uh we know that he's never been a
good candidate talking about Biden what
are you talking about Charlamagne you
were kissing his ass on your podcast and
he a white guy in front of you said if
you have a problem deciding whether
you're for me or Trump then you ain't
black and you didn't say [__] okay so I
don't I don't play that [__] now now
all of a sudden everybody's coming back
to the oh no we never thought yes you
did bro you were kissing his ass number
one number two um Adam great point about
Michelle and the voting block for if
Michelle runs and that was a great Point
uh on your show when we were asking you
as the panel and they were all girls but
couple of them were African-American
girls and you're like who' you best
president ever what did they say every
single black person went well I have to
check the box and Barack Obama what did
they what do he do well I don't know but
I just I have to vote for him because
why no qualifications no nothing what
makes Michelle Obama I mean I I
guarantee you it'd be a it'd be a fight
what makes her a good candidate what
because she was the wife of a that's why
I to I'm like what has she ever [__]
done but guess what though if people
next thing you know we're vot we're
voting for uh Melania Trump next time
around that's my but that's my point
Adam ready for this they're going to go
demon devil Satan Hitler orange guys
coming back or Michelle Obama That's the
safe cool you know America just you know
they want to get coddled and they want
to be nice even though they're going to
get screwed in the ass that's I am not
voting for a Michelle Obama Harris
ticket and I doubt most Americans would
the question though how loyal you to
your party if you are a democr I'm a
registered independent I'm a registered
independent would you sit it out or
would you vote for Trump or Michelle if
it came down to those two votes I would
not vote for Michelle Obama so would you
vote for Trump yeah I love you let's go
Adam the way that's America right there
baby yeah and and when you're saying
when you're saying by the way this was a
Monumental moment hearing this guy here
he would vote and that's a great thing
about I think a lot of people are
basically waking up what I I think he's
right by the way you remember this
Vinnie one thing one thing you never do
in in in a world of competition and
there's no game no competitive sport
that's more deceptive and dark and
manipulative than this game yeah okay so
what does this mean I if if there's any
game that there's competition never un
underestimate opponent and this one is
the most deceptive one You definitely
cannot underestimate who these people
are Michelle Obama I know you're like
wow who is she what has she done on her
life okay this this she went to a great
school she went to Princeton and she
graduated in what 1981 graduating cumad
okay in
85 uh uh with a 99 page senior thesis
titled Princeton educated blacks and
black community I mean this is like a
fully qualified person for this she
majored in sociology MH minored in
African-American studies okay had a
double major in Dei yeah I mean you know
that's a whole different story then she
continues and gets her law license okay
and she actually when they were running
I don't know why I remember this she was
making very good income uh out of the
tax I remember that I thought she was
making 150k year in 2006 he ran two
years later when they did their annual
salary couple's tax returns in 2006 her
salary in 2006 was
$273,000 a year
okay and he was making
157 she was making
$120,000 more per year than him which
many would say she's more qualified to
run than he is okay so this is this is
not somebody that and on top of that
very well spoken incredible campaigner
when she would go up there and you know
do what she did with the speeches and
all that she got the votes you cannot
underestimate the power of Michelle
Obama and the game she's going to bring
and the average personal pet like
everything that you wrote the average
person in here out there they don't they
don't know that it's just Michelle Obama
because as we're learning right now Pat
Biden is not making a single decision so
it's because you know who they're saying
is running the white house right now
Barack Obama okay let's be honest but
and he even said it he said it in an
interview and he goes listen if there is
some type of way that I could you know
get on the earpiece and and he admits
what he's doing he's in charge Hillary's
in charge couple of other big names
because when Joe Biden says and I quote
I I I can't say anything because they
said that I can't that's the they
everybody's always wondering who's the
they Michelle and I I agree with you
100% I'm not underestimating her but
what I'm what I'm saying is nobody knows
about any of those qualifications she's
the best pick because she's what America
would be like I don't know what do you
mean by the way her book sold nearly 20
million copies I again I understand what
you're saying I'm just saying she is
formidable and if you get Michelle guess
who you get automatically with Michelle
you get Barack of course and then if you
get Nome you know who else do you get
with Nome you get all the people that
are the establishment side back in the
family
palal listen NSA Michelle I guarantee
you on the Insight Insight Insight
insight inside of Trump's Camp they know
like if I'm if I'm playing like you know
how you're playing you know you're going
you're going through playoffs and you're
like okay first round we're going to
take these guys that we're going to Win
4 to2 okay let's just try to sweep these
guys but it's probably going to be 4 to2
and I'm talking NBA football there's
luck involved basketball there's not a
lot of luck involv the best team
typically in in the sport yeah seven
games so typically the best team in
basketball typically wins not all the
time but typically wins in football
that's not the case Any Given Sunday Mar
yeah you never know
I guarantee on the inside they have to
look at the matchups so while they're
picking and choosing they have to this
is why I don't think it's good to choose
the VP too early I think let's wait for
the matchups let's see who the matchups
are hang tight okay you would much
rather have them pick their candidates
than yours and someone on the inside is
going to leak inform formation on the
left they're going to but it's GNA
happen when they leak it and when that
leak happens then you have to Pivot and
have the right team let me let me just
give one perspective cuz you know just
how you just get laid out how Trump and
his team are basically strategizing
what's going to happen so is the DNC and
what they're basically saying to Biden
is like your only chance is against
Trump because if somehow Dan santis who
just dropped out is in this race or even
if it's Nikki Haley all the polling says
that they would wipe your ass off the
map cuz they're young they're vibrant
your only chance is to go after Mr
anti-democracy January 6th Donald Trump
that's why the election is even remotely
close at this point so the DNC is
basically saying the only way we're
parading or propping up Joe Biden is
against Trump now I still think based on
polling and even in the bottle
Battleground States Trump is likely to
win he's the favorite at this point but
they're they're more excited about Trump
than a than a Nikki Haley in the middle
of yeah in the middle of your Kur fuffle
here Kur fuffle I love that you guys
were saying what stories are coming out
what stories are coming out this story
isn't coming out there's no story about
who's going to be it it's it's
completely suppressed and it's
completely quiet and it's completely
behind closed doors you all you have to
do is look at what stories are coming
out yeah and what's coming out Obama the
leaks that Obama talked to him the
laptop things just look at the stories
that are coming out in unison not from
secondary sources not from the hill not
from political not from Fox but from the
mainstream media look at those stories
and just connect those do well well
guess what and here's my thing if you
like crime if you really love inflation
if you love an open border and people
[__] and pissing outside your door
if you like a cup of urine on the front
porch yeah and if you you love
homelessness keep voting no keep voting
for Democrats because that's that's what
they want it won't stop with Michelle it
definitely won't stop with Gavin Newsome
because he has a shitty CRA uh track
record that's what you vote for but
people like you said for circling back
they go off a motion they're be like oh
M it's Michelle Obama What could goong
nothing is going to change as Barack
says so bck me if you guys want to talk
about all right gang uh great podcast
today we will not be having a podcast
tomorrow nor Thursday but I do believe
we make it back on our flight to be able
to do something Friday afternoon if I'm
not mistaken do we have something Friday
afternoon Rob we do 2: to 4 p.m. right
now 2: to 4 P p.m. Friday afternoon okay
gang have a great day we'll see you guys
on Friday take care bye- bye bye-
bye